hey youtubers it's Charlie so there's
new flash footage so I'm gonna do a
breakdown in because they've been kind
of weird with the way that I use footage
I'm gonna just break this up a little
bit
there's some weird worlds about posting
trailers on YouTube so so if you ever
see me using or not using footage
there's actually a really good reason
for it real quick reminder to new round
of the reverse flash ring giveaway all
you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on this
video but the important thing here is
that they kind of explained the
relationship that Jay Garrick is gonna
have with Barry this season he's gonna
be kind of like a mentor now in the
comics usually Jay Garrick is a much
older person he's still much older than
Barry but our version of Barry is like a
twenty-something Barry he's not the
thirty forty something Barry that we
usually see in the comics so everybody
has aged down just a little bit there's
also some behind-the-scenes footage of
them showing how Jay Garrick's gonna
look running it looks like his
lightening is exactly like Barry's he's
like the earth-2 version of Barry
there's no Barry Allen flash on earth-2
and it looks like they're actually doing
the flash of two worlds comic book cover
scene I think that's kind of funny
usually it's really awesome when they
pay attention to details like that as
long as they don't do it too much like
they're not gonna do something like that
every single episode
it's just that introducing Jay Garrick
is one of the biggest things the show
has ever done so it's perfect for doing
a very over-the-top comic book moment
like this this of course is patty spivot
they talked a little bit about her in
the sneak peek and what's going on with
her and Barry she's gonna be Joe's new
partner remember
r.i.p eddie pour drink out for him
she'll be a new romantic interest for
Barry for however long they obviously
they said that things like that don't
last so like if you're not a big fan of
Oliver and Felicity on arrow that's also
probably not gonna last for forever
either one of the most fun things is
watching them explore relationships you
know getting really comfortable with
that and then just yanking the rug out
from under everyone irises storyline
this year is probably to be much more
rewarding because it's not gonna be
based all about her feelings about Barry
she's still working at the paper so
hopefully we're gonna see a lot of Linda
Park when she's around too and speaking
of relationships obviously firestorms
gonna be in the first couple of episodes
I don't know how many exactly but it
seems like they're holding off on the
killer frost stuff so I'm wondering if
something weird is gonna happen with
their relationship around midseason and
it's gonna push Caitlin over the edge
I'm just I'm not gonna hold my breath
for a killer frost the first half of the
season they've already got all their new
characters they have to introduce all
their new comic book characters and the
legends of tomorrow characters that they
have to debut so if you're wondering why
we don't see Grodd and we don't
killer frost and some of the other big
stuff the first half of the season it's
just because there's so many other
things that they're already trying to do
I'm really diggin the action with Jay
Garrick I think that he and Barry are
gonna have a lot of fun like Barry's
kind of riding high he's still kind of
depressed about Eddie dying so these are
Jay Garrick showing up in his life is
gonna give him renewed purpose
especially this mission to defeat zoom
I've still been seeing a lot of
questions about zoom in professor zoom I
think a lot of people who have the
comics don't understand that those are
two different characters so when people
talk about zoom they're not talking
about professor zoom a Bart Thawne
they're talking about hunters Oh Lamont
now that's not who zoom of the TV show
is gonna be and in both those characters
have yellow suits they look very similar
so the TV show is just gonna change what
zoom looks like so that he doesn't look
like the season 1 reverse flash eobard
thawne but even though we don't see him
in a lot of these trailers Harrison
wells will be a part of season 2 it's
just that he'll be from earth to he'll
be the earth to Harrison wells
that's why I think in this scene they're
all making WTF faces because they turn
around and they see Harrison wells and
they're like oh my god didn't we just
see you die
aren't you the reverse-flash in that and
then Jay Garrick walks in and explains
and we see Caitlin put his helmet back
on seriously this is gonna be so awesome
also really important is Martin Stein
here now Cisco is kind of like the
explainer character he takes really
complex scientific explanations and
makes them into pop-culture references
and jokes so Martin Stein is probably
gonna be the one to explain the
multiverse and then Cisco I'll be making
all the jokes about it a couple of
things that we haven't seen in any of
the trailers yet are jesse quick and
wally west
now they cast wally west a long time ago
so they probably have footage of him
they don't want to release yet they do
they want to keep that a surprise but
Jesse quick was cast relatively late but
they should still have her in the first
couple of episodes and no I don't think
that all of them are gonna be speedsters
in the first season just because they're
speedsters in the comics doesn't mean
they're gonna be speedsters right away
wally west iris west Jesse quick Linda
Park all of them have had Speed Force
powers in the comics at various points
but the TV show isn't gonna be doing
powers for everyone all at the same time
that would make it so not a special
thing everybody is not allowed to be
special if you ever saw The Incredibles
that's the explanation everybody can't
be special if everyone's special then by
default no one is special so for at
least the first half of the season I
think the only people we're gonna see
with Speed Force powers are big bad zoom
Jay Garrick Barry Allen
maybe wally west what i'd really like to
see is like if the midseason finale we
see another lightning accident and wally
west gets his powers but you guys can
let me know of all the new characters
which of them do you want to see get
Speed Force powers or do you think that
none of them are gonna get Speed Force
powers in season two I know a lot of you
guys have also been asking about arrow
season 4 footage still waiting on more
stuff from that they've been posting a
whole bunch of flash stuff but there
just hasn't been a lot of arrow stuff
posting the DVDs did go on sale today so
for those of you that are waiting for
flash and arrow to hit Netflix it should
happen in the next couple of weeks
Warner Brothers did this thing last year
where they held off on Netflix to the
weeks before the show aired the
reasoning is is that they don't want to
cannibalize their DVD sales they make a
ton of money on DVD sales and if they
put it on Netflix then it's like why do
you need to buy the DVDs so whatever
they'll be on Netflix pretty soon anyway
I think Gotham Season one actually just
hit Netflix 2 so if you haven't seen
Gotham season 1 yet you can check it out
on Netflix I'm hoping for some arrow
season 4 footage tomorrow but just in
case it doesn't post I'm still gonna do
an arrow flash related video and I'll
name the winner of this week's giveaway
in that video and I also I almost forgot
Gotham actually just confirmed that it's
doing court of owls in season 2 so if
you ever wanted a reason to watch Gotham
that's it
court of owls one of the best Batman
stories of the last ten years so why you
guys wait for all that stuff to post you
can click here for my Gotham season 2
episode 1 video and you can click here
for the latest Supergirl trailer
breakdown they just have some of the
comic book characters in it thank you so
much for watching everybody let's high
five I'll see you guys tonight